and we are very happy that Kevin Kiley
is joining us now from California Kevin
now apparently AP is still not
officially called this race but it is a
done deal your reaction tonight to being
lucky number 218 I'm so thrilled about
this
well thanks Laura yeah it's been called
by decision desk and so uh you know very
excited to come in and push us over into
the majority and bring some new
leadership that is desperately needed in
this country you know the House of
Representatives is the part of our
government that is most responsive to
public opinion that's the way the
framers designed it that's the way our
constitution was designed and so by
electing a new majority in the house the
American people have said we need change
and so I'm excited to get to work with
our new majority to deliver that change
well you'll be shocked to know that Eric
swalwell another California Congressman
had a slightly different take on the
midterms
the voters are clearly rejected chaos
and that's what the Republicans ran on
and they awarded competence and we ran
on the infrastructure Bill the chips act
the rescue plan and that frame worked in
our Direction it was really a win for
democracy
was using the same same line as
McConnell about things Kevin your
response to that
well no I mean clearly what we've seen
is that there are record levels of
dissatisfaction with the American people
right now when it comes to the economy
when it comes to the absolutely open
border when it comes to Rising crime
across this country when it comes to the
assault on parental rights and education
you see that Americans are registering
levels of dissatisfaction that we really
have not seen and so by electing a
republican house we they have now sent a
signal that they're looking for Change
and so I think that now when you have a
Democrat let's Senate when you have the
Biden Administration in control of the
White House the House of Representatives
is now the vehicle for effectivating
that game what you're going to see is uh
you know I was getting to work right
away to deal with the border to get
inflation under control to get crime
under control and to use the oversight
Powers the oversight Powers The subpoena
Powers the ability to question members
of parts of the administration to get to
the facts we're going to put that to use
immediately to bring some accountability
which Nancy Pelosi's Congress has
steadfastly refused to do for the last
two years all right Kevin thank you and
congratulations again maybe this is the
beginning of something really great in
California hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else